she passed away
oh
all right Tommy Lee's wife Brittany
Ferlin gets slammed over that since
deleted Tick Tock suggesting Tommy's ex
Pamela Anderson wouldn't care if she
died in the video Britney seems unfazed
using a 90s Pam makeup filter alongside
the text Pam if I died she passed away
hey
all right this all comes after the
release of the Baywatch Stars Memoir
love Pamela and the Netflix documentary
Pamela a love story where the former
Playmate reflects on her past
relationship with Tommy I think what it
all comes down to is that I never cut
over
not being able to make it work with the
father of my kids I think that's
probably why I keep failing in all my
relationships
Brittany noted in the caption please
guys I gotta make jokes it's how I cope
she passed away
oh
all right but people online weren't
feeling all that and called Brittany out
many sharing examples of the many times
Pam said she respects her ex's marriage
he has someone really wonderful in his
life I'm really happy for them Pam even
empathized with Britney acknowledging
that she might feel some kind of way
about all the Press surrounding her
Netflix stock I hate to be annoying and
going through this again and for sure
she's annoyed but
um I respect their relationship and just
glad he's happy well Brittany who
married the Motley Crew drummer in 2019
has since deleted that controversial
Tick-Tock video and she previously told
fans not to worry about her following
the documentary's release
I just wanted to come on here to let you
know that I'm okay so I don't sweat the
comments from people who don't know me
or my relationship I'm lucky to have a
really loving husband who honestly
laughs all this stuff off and could care
less of course Tommy and Pamela tied the
knot in 1995. yeah Meredith Pamela yeah
oh okay now you remember me okay got it
they welcomed two sons Brandon and Dylan
before divorcing in 1998.
in her Memoir Pam says the split from
the musician was the hardest lowest most
difficult point of her life but now with
a new book and documentary out she has a
lot to celebrate we decided to release
everything on the same day just feels
like kind of a surreal Divine timing
Redemptive feeling it just feels
surreal E.T caught up with Pam at the LA
premiere for her Netflix stock where she
thanked her son Brandon for encouraging
her to tell her story he's such a great
kid and so creative and
really just put this whole thing
together he's he's really who knows when
you're who knew when you're having
children that they would grow up and
actually
it was a reason it all kind of happened
like this is all feels so meant to be
it's like this Divine timing and I it
feels surreal to me but I'm very proud
of him
[Music]